foreign
[Music]
news to start the stream over the past
three months or so I want to say I'm
Alexander maybe yeah approximately since
the New Year Board Nick and I
all of you guys know who bordnick is I
don't really need to introduce him we've
been working on
a course on an opening that we both have
we're one of the first people to play
which was the jababa London
so the jababa London is an opening that
goes well you've seen me play it a
million times I play it I practice what
I preach so it's D4 Knight F6 Knight C3
or D4 D5 Knight C3 Knight F6 and Bishop
F4 this is the jabala London
and we just about 30 minutes ago
published a course that we've been
working on for
three months or so I would estimate you
know yesterday I said over 50 but we
kind of estimated the amount of time
that we spend on this course and we came
to a number closer to 100 hours
on this course it includes all of
Black's responses to Bishop F4 it's very
very comprehensive and it is basically a
total labor of love so the course is out
I've never published a course before so
hopefully all of the tech works we
bought it ourselves to make sure that
you can download the pgns easily and we
were able to download them but you can
check out the link
and you can let me know obviously like
urgently let me know if you can't access
something but hopefully everything works
out this is my first our first ever
opening course we neither of us has ever
done this before so if this turns out
well and the course is popular and
people like it the most importantly then
hopefully this will be the start of many
courses on both the opening and the
middle game which is something I've
wanted to do for a very long time
but I learned a lot of lessons as we did
this course one of which is that it's
very very hard to do an opening course
on your own
because of the scope of analysis
with this is not a video These are pgns
so there's no video
how is this different from a chessable
course we're both super excited because
we have worked on this we have worked
our freaking asses off
and I would never put my name in front
of something that I didn't think was
like Top Class content hopefully people
know that by now I would most certainly
never charge money for anything that I
thought was not worth charging money for
so I'm like super proud of the work that
we did I'll talk a little bit about some
of the stuff that we analyzed and give
you a sneak preview the point is not to
chill this out and get anybody who
doesn't want to buy it to buy it this is
like entirely it's just out there I want
to create a very low pressure
environment where if you feel like this
will contribute to your play and this
will materially improve your results
then you should get it if not you
absolutely should not get it so I I will
have an unorthodox sales approach so
I'll talk about this in a moment I'll
tell you how to open PGN files it's easy
you can do it with chess.com you can do
it with leeches you don't need any
additional software to open the files so
everything's like meant to be as easy as
possible I'll be right back I also need
to run to the bathroom so then I'll talk
more about the course
so let's address a couple of things
first
first of all what is this course on we
cover all of Black's responses in this
position that includes C5
C6 Bishop F5 E6
A6 G6 Knight bd7 Knight C6 Bishop G4
we also cover in depth this line which
is pretty popular at a high level
these are the contents of the course
what do the files look like so there is
no video component which is why we
looked at what chessable courses charge
without video I think adjustable courses
are around 50 60 so that's that was our
sort of General metric I'm going to
answer questions one by one so just be
patient what is the skill level for the
course this course is designed really
for beginner to master I would like GMS
to consider getting this course we
held ourselves to a standard such that a
GM who got this course would be happy
with the analysis and would find
interesting ideas in that course we also
designed it with an eye toward most of
the audience who we think is going to be
you know beginner to intermediate
obviously it's not geared for people who
have just learned the rules of the game
but hopefully that is kind of
self-evident
but really anybody a thousand and over I
think can benefit from building a
sustainable opening repertoire in which
you actually know what you're playing
and in which you can basically guarantee
getting better positions or even winning
positions every single game out of the
opening
next set of questions what about the
Hans Neiman course so there's a couple
of available literatures on the jabala
London in existence the first is
this book
the jababa London and I'm going to
explain how our course is different why
it's necessary to make another course
and why you can't just get hanza's score
I mean you can get hans's course
there is a book written by Simon
Williams who most of you know called the
chababa London system this was written
in 2022. it's pretty recent this is a
very basic exposition of the ideas
now obviously
this book is a good introduction to the
system but we believe that a lot of
Simon's recommendations are
deviate from ours and this book is not
really analysis based right it's based
on giving a bunch of model games I think
it's a good book but it doesn't really
give you knowledge of the theory of how
to play the opening
um
in terms of the Hans trustable course I
have a criticism of the majority of
chessable courses
by which I don't mean to imply that the
author doesn't put in tremendous effort
I own a ton of chessable courses I think
trustable is amazing I think most
courses are really good I think hanz's
course is really good
but the biggest issue that I have with a
lot of trustable courses is that they
cover essentially the lines that occur
at the top level but what Sasha and I
realized when we were checking the
chess.com in leeches database is that
the moves that people actually play very
often do not correspond in the least
to the lines given in the chessable
course because people don't know the
theory of obscure openings and so we
decided to make a course that actually
focuses on we give all the best moves
obviously we give the best lines we
analyze them to exhaustion but we're
focusing on the moves that you're likely
to actually face and we indicate that
clearly in all of the files so for
example if you take the system with E6
the move we recommend here is Knight to
B5
and black basically has three responses
here let's see if you guys can name the
three main responses for black in this
position
black has three in ways to defend C7 to
our obvious one is less obvious let's
see if you can name all three
no E5 is not a move
E5 just take
Bishop B4 is one of them that's the most
obscure
but that's what most GMS choose beef
Bishop before Bishop A5 there's Knight
A6 and there's Bishop D6
so the most popular move on leeches is
actually Bishop D6 this is the worst of
the three moves and yet it is the most
popular and with full due respect to
Hans nothing I'm about to say is in any
way intended to knock on hanza's work
again hopefully will not be interpreted
that way before I continue those
watching from YouTube
I will now authorize
this course it is official it's not a
scam I posted on in the YouTube
Community tab about the course it's real
it's not a troll it's not a scam my
account was not hijacked this course is
real and I'm putting my name in front of
it
so
this move is the most common by far and
Hans dedicates only one variation to
this line after E3 he gives a move
that's almost never played on Lee chess
which is Queen to B6 and we gave Queen
B6 but vast majority of people just end
up castling and this is my problem with
most decimal courses you're basically on
your own
in a line that's going to occur at least
like 30 percent of the time so this is
what we analyzed with an eye toward
actually giving you directions that are
going to help you in the games you face
so this line is much more common than
black putting the queen on B6 and
there's a million lines like that
so that is how I would say our course
deviates conceptually in terms of the
actual moves we did not use hans's
course at all we checked it occasionally
some lines correspond obviously because
in some variations there's just no room
for deviation for example after C5 we
both give this very sharp Dynamic new
move E4 and yet our recommendations
later on in this line deviate completely
and we believe that we've found a lot
more dangerous and more interesting
lines in some of the main C5 variations
in the bishop F5 lines as well
so that's another thing to keep in mind
in terms of the lack of video we thought
about when we came up with the idea of
making the course and that happened when
Alexander was in Charlotte for a
tournament you know we've known each
other for a long time and we kind of
hatched this idea you know let's make an
opening course and what do we make it on
well there's an opening that we both
have been playing since 2015 since well
before it was cool now everybody plays
it Alexander has been playing it even
before me he's one of the original
players to develop a lot of the ideas
you know we said all right so let's do
this course and let's have a video
component then we realized that like the
video component takes at least another
100 hours and I personally never buy the
chessable courses with the video because
it's like six times as expensive and I
feel like if the pgns are properly
annotated then the video has limited
value and what we try to do is basically
textually annotate every single imported
move
so you're basically getting the video
component in the actual file every Big
Move is explained there's a ton of
textual explanation we didn't explain
everything and there's going to be some
omissions but we tried our best to use
the text to guide you in the right
direction
and obviously we didn't want to do an
over complicated system where we charge
one thing for the video and one thing
without the video we just want one price
you know what you're getting you get the
files boom you analyze them that's it
that's the next thing
then I just wanted to address
why you know you should play this
opening like why the jabab London so I
personally think that at an intermediate
level this opening is one of the most
underrated that you can play of course
the traditional London system is super
popular now but I think it's rather
Toothless and while it is likely to give
you a good position you're not really
playing to win the game out of the
opening the big difference is that in
the jabala London you're basically
playing for the win right out of the
gates in fact so much so the black has
already two losing moves in this
position Knight C6 loses the game
tonight to B5 black has no way to defend
C7 Knight bd7
Knight B5 also loses the game so you
have two trap lines you have a million
lines where black loses in under 10
moves just yesterday I played a game
against an IM
and uh I won in 10 moves basically he
played Bishop F5 our recommendation is
E3 E6 Knight F3 and what's great about
this line is how symmetrical it looks
and how deceptive it is
black can lose this in like a couple of
moves
and what often happens is after NBD 795
a lot of players they play something
like A6 and already after G4 black is
borderline lost this trick with G4 and
H4
is ridiculously common in the jababa
London
and it causes immediate catastrophic
problems for black because the threat is
H5 you trap the bishop that's how the
game continued
this is how the game went and I was
winning in 11 moves because the bishop
is trapped and you'll see a lot of lines
like this
if black plays in any such position H6
then you take the bishop and you
completely ruin the pawn structure and
then you go after the G6 Pawn black is
just losing here because he's got to
bring the king out and now you play
Queen F3 pinning the pinning the king
and G5 is coming next and you're
completely winning out of the opening I
really really think that adding this to
your repertoire will help
essentially guarantee fun positions
better positions and you'll feel like a
freaking badass next question was what
happens if somebody counter researches
so yeah obviously
if somebody prepares diligently and like
buys our course and spends another 50
hours analyzing with an engine black
equalizes in the jabalon and we don't
pretend at any moment in the course that
this gives white an advantage
if black plays perfectly black is maybe
four or five lines that equalize but
even in those equalizing lines we were
able to find really challenging ideas so
even if your opponent goes 10 12
computer moves in a row we're posing
serious problems and a lot of the lines
end on move 20 move 25 so we're really
trying to like
give players of all levels directions if
you're on a lower level if you're a
beginner to intermediate you're probably
not going to face the best lines very
often if you're 2200 we still want you
to get the course and we believe that
you know you're going to benefit from it
as well that's why we were as
comprehensive as we were the NIMS are
there's no such thing you can't well so
here's the downside of the course here's
what we didn't cover and this might be
for the next course what we didn't cover
is the movie six you have to be ready to
go into the French we did not cover the
French we will do that I think in our
next course but I will tell you that
about 95 of people either they play D5
and if they don't play D5
then they're not French players
and if you go into the French against a
non-french player most of the time
you're going to win the game pretty
quickly so is it a good idea to research
this line for five ten minutes yes but
we felt that we have to like frame our
work in reasonable ways and analyzing
the French would have taken us another
you know another 50 hours so we're gonna
save that for subsequent course the
other thing that we didn't cover is the
sort of benoni setup which is pretty bad
for black c5d5 is just better for white
d64 is an inferior benoni for black
so we might do a course Edition where we
cover E6 and C5 but again the course
itself is on the jabab London which is
D5 Bishop F4 we also cover D5 Knight C3
and Bishop F5
um all of the other moves transpose into
E4 openings such as c64 and E64 and this
will be for subsequent courses and of
course you can still play Bishop F4 and
most of the time you're going to
transpose back into the jabala London 98
of the time you're gonna get
you know Knight F6 on the next move so
in any case that's kind of the contents
of the course I don't want to paste in
any files because people might
photograph them with their phone
in terms of the pricing and you know
what we're hoping that you'll get out of
it so we decided on a price of 50 bucks
we might run a sale later on it was
tough to set up the payment and stuff I
hope that like we get the payments and
stuff we tried to find a site a course
hosting site that's easy to buy and
isn't intrusive to your information so
this site that we chose there's like
five or six of them is pretty
straightforward to use I mean you enter
your email address and that's basically
it and then you enter your credit card
details and that's it
and it you know it just gives you the
file
so why did we choose on you know select
fifty dollars we wanted something that
feels reasonable
we didn't want to make you feel like you
are going down a path of no return like
you know you're buying a 300 course and
then if it's not what you expected
you know we don't want a situation where
you feel like you feel cheated or
scammed
and we compared it to most accessible
courses we thought it was a reasonable
price given the amount of work that we
put in as well as you know what you
basically get out of it which is
essentially with the exception of a few
lines a complete opening repertoire for
the white pieces
oh yeah how to open pgns I wanted to say
so all you have to do is download it and
then on chess.com analysis or on Lee
chess you can literally just click
upload PGN and it uploads the files you
don't need to download anything extra
yeah so for example
if we take a PGN file let me create a
PGN file I'll show you how to do it
before example let me take a random game
I'm going to take a random opening
course I'm going to show you what I have
right now in the Danish Gambit
for instance I'm working right now on
a Danish Gambit file and I'll upload it
so basically on just.com analysis you
can do this on lead chest as well it's
exactly the same way you have the
analysis all you have to do is upload
upload file but you basically click
upload file you go to your downloads
folder wherever you downloaded your the
files open the file
and you click add game
and that's it and then you get the file
and this is what a PGN file actually
looks like this is my endglen file which
I uploaded to leeches
and it's based on the YouTube video I
made this is what it looks like there's
text and there's moves now chess.com's
PGN viewer is not amazing you have to
use your mouse to go between the lines
but the parentheses indicate different
lines on one move the line without the
parentheses is the main line
and what we did in the course is we
broke it down every which way so you
have one file that has all of the lines
in one and then you have individual
chapters that correspond to Black's
various options but that's all there is
to it this is what a PGM looks like
you know it's of they're obviously a lot
longer than this but that's uh that's
basically it can you estimate the number
of book pages well okay that depends on
the font size in terms of pure
variations maybe like 50 I don't know
it's it's it's really really hard to say
well I'm getting we're getting a lot of
purchases this is awesome
again
if you're unsatisfied or you feel like
you are not getting your money's worth I
want people to be honest like I don't
want this to be just another like oh you
know this is amazing if you found it
amazing I'd like to hear about it but if
you found it unsatisfactory I'd also
like to hear about it whatever the
unadulterated truth is I can take it
because this will help us figure out
whether it's worth making more courses
and whether you feel like it actually
impacts your play that's the bottom line
is you want we want you to feel like you
your chest has improved materially as a
result of getting this course that
that's any course should be made with
that philosophy in mind I think how long
does it take to memorize well again
that's it's I don't think it can be
memorized there's too much analysis
can we see how it looks on leeches sure
so on leeches
so all you have to do is choose file you
can't see me choosing the file because
I'm not sharing that part of my screen
but for instance
you can click
um
ending the England and there we go this
is what Alicia's PGN looks like so this
is the Danish Gambit file which you can
kind of get a sneak preview but I
haven't actually published this anywhere
um but the leeches PGN viewer is much
nicer it's uh well not much nicer it is
nice because you can use the arrow keys
and go between the lines
and that's basically it it's very very
intuitive
it has like color-coded moves to help
you Orient yourself there's text on the
right side but if there's a long amount
of text then you're gonna have you have
to scroll down to read the entirety of
it so for example here there's a long
bit of text you have to click on this
little speech bubble and read it down
here
and read it down here and that's it
again you don't need to download Chess
base or get anything additional what do
you think the best way to tackle the
courses well I think the best way to
tackle the course is to download all the
files
and then
to
you know to basically tell yourself how
many hours you have to spend on it and
then just to like time yourself you know
you take like 30 45 minutes on each
chapter
you you run through it you you memorize
the main lines and then you start
playing it online the best way I think
to work with an opening course is
actually to play a ton of Blitz Games in
the opening and then every time you
encounter an unknown line you check the
file our goal is that more often than
not you will find the line that you face
to be analyzed extensively in the course
is everything that you're going to face
always going to be in the course
obviously not they're like really dumb
moves that you're going to face which
are not in the course if that's the case
then you know course doesn't mean every
single move is analyzed it means you
have a base you can learn all the ideas
but you you still will have to like
check certain like really really obscure
most of the engine
chest Tempo also has a PGN viewer by the
way totally free
how many chapters so last thing I'll say
and then I will leave you guys alone
with this
there are chapters on so here's how many
there are there are
so there's one that's D5 and Bishop F5
there is two three four five six seven
yeah so seven chapters total covering
essentially all of the legal moves in
this position it's hard to find a move
that we didn't cover I guess H6 we
didn't cover but in like Queen D6 and
stuff like that or like E5
but they're really really stupid moves
we didn't we we didn't waste time on but
essentially all of the lines that that
occur in leeches we looked at the very
topical H6 was omitted I am a big
proponent of opening memorization I
think people
try to Sugar goat the process of
learning openings whereas a lot of it
just is Brute Force memorization
no like I just said leeches does have a
great PGN viewer I recommend leeches or
uh now obviously what could happen is
somebody could pirate this and
distribute copies of the course
on leeches or otherwise we simply hope
that that's not going to happen we will
be monitoring like leeches and stuff to
make sure that nobody's like posting it
My Hope Is that people will respect you
know the work that we put in and play by
the rules we can't guarantee that and
that is the big downside of not having a
chessable course chessable automatically
has like security and that it's hard to
reproduce it's not impossible to make a
PGN out of a chest well you can do it
manually
but here it's quite easy to Pirate it if
you're so inclined so if you if you do
that you know
then we throw our hands up but I
you know we've been very lucky to have a
great community so far I don't think
that's going to be a problem
all right I think that'll conclude the
advertising segment of this stream
shouldn't jababa do the course in the
Jabbar I mean listen if jababa did a
course in the jabala London I would buy
it
you you know it's just the name of the
opening
foreign
[Music]